(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] TikTok stars
- [In Unison] I'm a TikTok star
- [Narrator] Five are
posers, one is the real deal.
Our teams
- Hi, I'm Luisa.
- Hey, I'm Jennifer
- And we are the moms!
- My name is Eddie.
- My name is Ben.
- We're the dads.
- [Narrator] In a room full of liars
can these teams find the real deal?
Each team has 15 minutes
to find the real deal.
Anytime within those 15 minutes
a team can lock in their answer.
- Hi guys.
- [In Unison] Hi.
- So this is a question
for the whole group.
If you guys can all answer
how many followers do you have on TikTok?
- I have 2.3 million.
- 3.2 million.
- I have 5.2 million
- As of this morning, 962.
- 975 thousand.
- 15.4 million
- Got it, okay.
I have a question for number one.
- Okay.
- Do you know what the Renegade is?
- Oh, oh my gosh, yes I
do. You want me to do it?
- Can she do it? - Oh
my gosh, okay. (laughs)
- I decided asking the
TikTokers to do the renegade
because that's one of the
most popular dances when
TikTok first came out.
And so I figured, hey,
if they're a TikTok star
they've gotta know how
to do this thing at least
a little bit.
- This isn't my category.
- You're a TikTok star,
you should be used to it.
- I got it though. I got it.
- Renegade! Yeah. Hey. Oh, yeah!
(Group laughter)
(Siren blares)
- This question's for number two.
What is your genre like, what is it about?
- I like to consider myself more
of like a social experiment
and type man on the street.
What I do is I go out, I interview people
get cool reactions and
that's what picks me up.
- Okay.
- I have a question for number four.
- Yes?
- [Jennifer] Hi.
- Hi.
- You're so cute. (laughs)
- You too!
- What is your favorite thing
about being a TikTok star?
- Well, my TikTok platform
is based around my dog.
so I like that I was able
to blow up around my dog.
It's not like I have to,
you know, be a TikToker.
My dog is the TikToker. (laughs)
- For number six.
- When did you start your TikTok journey?
- So I actually started
right before the pandemic.
It was 2019 when TikTok first like blew up
but I didn't actually get a lot
of followers until about a year ago.
But I've been doing it
for like three years.
- How many followers do
you have on Instagram?
- On Instagram I have 300 thousand.
(WOW sound effect)
- We're ready to make an elimination.
- [Narrator] Each team will
try to find the real deal
by eliminating the imposters.
If both teams eliminate the same person
they will be removed from the game.
- We eliminated number six
there's just something
that was lacking as far
as that star quality, if you will.
Sweet kid don't get me wrong, but.
- My question is for number two,
when did you get verified on TikTok?
- I'm actually not verified
yet, sadly, but people
in my niche don't really,
it's not really fun.
People don't really verify it
- Sounds good.
Question for, number one
do you do any type of
affiliate marketing on TikTok?
- Yes, a little bit.
So once I did, it's called
a Color Pop and Chiswell.
It was back in 2021, it
was like a makeup collab
and I also did a Detox your feed by Dove.
- Okay, sounds good.
Question for, number five how much time
do you spend on TikTok on average? Daily.
- Like maybe 30 minutes.
- 30 minutes a day?
- [Number 5] Yeah, not a
lot. The content I make
I don't really have to like
look at inspiration in a way.
- Oh, that's good. What
type of content do you make?
- I post about my music.
- Oh, okay.
Oh, what type of music do you do?
- Like sad ballad stuff about dead people.
(record scratch)
- Sounds good.
Okay, we're ready for our elimination.
- [Narrator] As a reminder, if both teams
eliminate the same person
that person will be removed from the game.
(whispering)
- We eliminated number two
he was trying to be too outward
and too a little bit overbearing so
we knew he was trying to put up a front.
- Number three.
How long have you been a TikTok star?
- I've been a TikTok star since 2019.
It was really easy to gain followers
and basically views back
then because the algorithm
you know, it just like caught
on like whoever it liked
and it chose me I guess so.
- Got it. Do you live in the LA area?
- I don't live in the LA area.
I live in a small town
in Sacramento and yeah.
- Okay, okay.
- We're ready to make an elimination.
- (whispers) Oh, can we do
more than one elimination?
- [Narrator] (whispers) just one.
- Okay.
- [Luisa] He was really
nervous from the get go.
He was super nervous.
- All right, so my
question is for number six
what type of videos do you make again?
- I do comedy, so I do
like comedy sketches
comedy with my dog. So right now
like I did one where my dog
I was filming a TikTok and my dog ran
and knocked over my ring
light, and it hit me the face.
- Okay, and how many
views did that one get?
- That one got like 6.3 million.
- [Eddie] 6.3. Thank you.
Question for number one
what was the video that
got you the most views?
- I'm a body positivity influencer
so I posted a video about
girls being flat chested.
- [Eddie] Okay.
- And that got a lot of views it got about
6 million views and the comments
were girls were relating
to me being like, oh,
like how do you do gain
Like confidence with this?
And that was basically my
videos. Those are my videos.
- Okay
- That's really cool.
I have a question for number three.
How much do you make on TikTok?
- I make about like, I don't know
like 10 thousand dollars from like
like 5.2 million views so.
And it also depends on like sponsors
and stuff like that, so yeah.
- Okay. I think might be
ready to make our elimination.
(spy music)
- [Narrator] Number three,
unfortunately our teams
do not believe that you are the real deal.
So we will have you exit the stage.
- But he is, he's the one.
- Good luck y'all.
- (laughs) He's the one.
- [Number 3] Bye, everybody.
- Well I have a question
for the entire group.
I would like to know what does
your day to day look like?
- I wake up, I usually
wake up really late like
at 1:00 PM and I work from about 3 to 10.
And then on the weekends
when have free time
it depends what I want to post.
- I wake up, I wait for
my friends to wake up,
we'll get on a call, come up with ideas.
And then we come up with an idea
and if we're feeling it
that day we'll go out
and film or maybe I won't.
- I wake up at like
7:30, I feed my chickens
and I see if they have
eggs, and then I probably
have some meetings then vocal
lessons and piano lessons.
- I'm a student too so
I'll either have class
or I'll be doing homework
or something like that.
And then I usually pre film my content
so I'll have drafts and
then I'll just post it
every day, I try to post every day.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- Yeah, we're ready to
make an elimination.
- [Luisa] We eliminated number four
simply because we didn't really
believe the puppy thing.
That's not really what kids are into
so just didn't seem real.
- All right, this question
actually goes to number five.
- Let me do one at a time then.
- Would you care to show us
some of your vocal skills?
- Oh.
- [Number 4] Oh my gosh
- ___
- Sure. ♪I'm only human after all.
I'm only human after all.
Don't put the blame on me,
don't put the blame on me.♪
(clapping) (laughter)
- [Jennifer] Okay, okay.
- We got to play it safe here, boys.
(laughter)
- And then this one's for the group.
Do you ever feel pressure
to post on TikTok?
Like if you have to, you
really don't want to.
- Yeah, especially if
you're like sick and you
don't wanna do it, (laughs)
but you just gotta do it.
- Personally, pressured, no.
My followers, they don't
really like get at me
like if I don't post because
I'm like a comfort to them.
- Not usually, I think it's obviously
when you have like maybe
a brand deal that you have to get done
by a certain date and you're not happy
with the way it is.
- I wish. I could say no, but I do
I, I feel like I don't get pressure
from other people but I
get pressure from myself.
I'm not as big as these guys,
so I only have like 975 K so I feel
like my TikTok is like barely blowing up.
So I feel like I do need to like keep
up with that in order to keep it growing.
- I think we found our elimination.
- (whispering) I'm thinking number six.
- (whispered speaking)
- [Narrator] TikToker number six
unfortunately both teams have decided
that you are not our real deal.
- Oh my god.
- [Number 6] Thank you, thank you
- [Narrator] And you will exit the stage.
- I thought he was six
five I'm not gonna lie.
- He's the one?
- [Number 5] That's the one yeah.
- I'm glad you guys like the song choice.
- We actually have a question
for the entire group.
So if you're out hanging out
chilling and a fan recognizes you
what is your interaction with them?
- Well my general interaction is like hi!
Like should I just like act out?
Hi. Like it's so good to see you!
- I don't get recognized. (laughs)
I mean sometimes like if
I'm talking to someone
at school they'll be like, oh yeah
I've seen your videos before.
But it's not like anything
cool like they were saying.
- Okay
- I'm a little awkward.
I get like really like,
I've just always been kind
of self-conscious cause
like I started doing it
in high school and everyone
kind of bullied me for it.
So I think it's more the things
like I don't believe they
actually like, like it.
- Okay.
- Okay. If you can tell us,
each of you tell us what
your monthly income is
and what the source like main source.
Is it like the views or is it-
- [Jennifer] Sponsorships?
- [Luisa] Yeah, that.
- So let's talk about views.
So I would say like about 5,000.
It really ranges honestly.
Like that's if I post a lot cause again
I post on my own time. So
I would say like monthly
about like about 2000 cause
it really depends on me.
- It's really less than you'd think.
Brands tend to stay away
from like prank content
and stuff like that.
The most I've ever gotten is
like the clothes that I'm
wearing or or stuff like that.
I'd say with that it's under 10 K.
- Yeah, like they're saying
you only get like 10 cents per view
if you're part of the
creator fund on TikTok.
So 5,000, the most I've
gotten a brand deal
before is 15,000 though.
So that was really exciting.
I can put it towards my tuition.
- Mid low six figures and then
it's kind of varies just cause like
the last three months I
haven't gotten a brand deal
but I obviously have the music and label
so I get paid off royalties
and when my music is
in TV shows and stuff.
- Okay.
- We're ready to make an elimination.
- TikTok star number two.
- Okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Narrator] TikTok star number two
unfortunately both have decided-
- [Group] No! Ain't no way.
- [Narrator] You are not our real deal.
- [Jennifer] We like you though, we do.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- We like you, but we like you
- You guys lost but it's
all right, it's all right.
(laughter)
- This question is for
number one and number four.
Are you guys verified?
And when did you apply to get verified?
- Me? I'm not verified.
I don't wanna apply like
honestly it's just me.
I don't look at my content
as something to get like really like-
- You're more authentic.
- [Number 1] Yeah, like
honestly like I don't really
look at that.
- [Ben] You're not doing
it for the monetization
or anything, that's true. (hits chest)
- [Number 1] No, I'm not
- And I'm not verified either.
They just don't like me.
(laughter)
- How many followers have you had
in the last 30 days? Number five.
- I haven't checked but,
like typically I range
from like 180 to 300 thousand a month.
- Okay.
- We're ready to lock in our guests.
- [Group] Sick. That
was so cool (laughter)
- Got em! (ding)
(laughs)
(spy music)
- Might as well yeah, yolo, yolo strategy.
(confirmation ding)
- Dads, you have decided
to lock in your real deal
which means your game is over
and the moms will continue
with 22 seconds left on their clock.
- Oh ____
- We are actually ready
to make our selection
for the real deal.
- Okay, so five?
- I think so.
(confirmation ding)
- [Narrator] Both teams
have decided to lock in their real deals
which means the game is officially over.
- We believe that number four
is the real deal holy field.
And the reason why is because
our money is on that puppy.
- We believe that the
real deal is number five.
- [Jennifer] We believe it's number five
because when you have some sort of fame
there's an air about you
that has to get used to that.
TikTok is such a crazy popular
thing and so if he's a star
he should be adjusted to people
and become more chill and not
be so busy in personality.
- [Narrator] Unfortunately number one
they have not chosen you as the real deal
so I'll ask you to please
step off the platform.
- I liked your renegade
- [Narrator] If the lights
on your podium turn green
that means that you have
chosen the real deal.
If your light turns red, that means
that you have actually chosen an imposter.
Because the dads were able
to lock in their real deal
first we'll reveal your answers to you.
3, 2, 1.
- No!
- (screams)
- Well we don't know yet!
- Yes, we did! (laughs) Just kidding.
That's just one down, sorry.
We just wanted make sure
they didn't win that.
That's it, that's what
we're really here for.
- [Narrator] Moving on to our moms.
You have chosen TikToker number five.
Your answer will be revealed in
3, 2, 1.
- (excited screaming)
Yeah! Haha I knew it!
- I'm so happy you guys
didn't ask me to renegade
oh my god.
(laughter)
- I knew it! I knew it!
- If you would've asked me to renegade
I would've ___ myself.
- Hi, I'm Alex Warren. I was not lying.
I have 15.4 million followers on TikTok
2 million on Instagram
and I'm actually signed
to Atlantic Records.
- [Moms] Wooo! That's awesome. (claps)
- [Alex] Yeah!
I don't feel like I'm a TikTok star
maybe just because everything
happened during quarantine.
I make content that I really
like and make music I really
like and it just means more
that people care about it.
I don't really care about the label of it.
I guess?
- The funny thing is
originally our choice was number five.
But then we thought it might have been
a little bit too obvious.
So Jubilee was trying to throw us off
which they do sometimes.
- (laughing)
- I just wanted to win, just
trying to beat the dads.
- I like genuinely speaking
like half of what they were saying.
They did their research, they seemed-
I know TikTok I lived in a content house.
They all first, second, I thought it was
in the hype house like it was.
It was some crazy ___!